[Music]
we're calling we won't know unless you
answer the telephone that is how the
telephone work I miss accent a moment I
was speaking to a colleague of mine at
Bell Laboratories he said they're
looking for bright young minds outside
about thinkers really
I've been mapping out this idea for
online module that indicates a college
name in the telephone ring
[Music]
okay ray bradbury save that for your
science fiction novels they're looking
for practical application
sometimes to realize a dream
the only voice worth listening to is
your own ITT is working on a go anywhere
phone but we we've got nothing
what if we had a display that informs
you who's calling
what is your room dr. Shirley Ann
Jackson well there's dr. Shirley Ann
Jackson I'd say you've been dipping into
your own medicine bag who could possibly
be calling this out wouldn't be great to
know there would how that's my boss sit
down - laughs anyone listen to me I'm
telling you you believe in yourself bang
got no choice but to believe in you
[Music]
calling line identification presentation
with an analogue system interface
calling line identification now I've
seen it all
choke your mother-in-law calls you don't
have to hear from executive producers
Pharrell Williams and Oprah Winfrey
comes the true story of one women
struggle to change our world starring
jasmine Simon as Shirley Ann Jackson
with ray wise and Frank lemon the studio
mandated roles avoid Savior this is
going to make those telemarketers think
twice about interrupting America's
family dinner and make us very very rich
men
[Music]
I'm no C equals mc-squared and I should
be able to cook this at 400 gree for 27
minutes and it not be dried I don't
really know what's going on I don't know
Morris I just
we need to pray on it good lord please
undriveable moisture deep deep into the
thigh meat here's my season the
vegetables would be blessing and some
extra salt
[Music]